Isabelle Leonardo DiCaprio is a producer
on the first film and a big champion of
yours when you got started have you seen
him throughout the years do you keep in
touch when you see him at events what's
that like I think the last time I saw
him was in person was at a like a
pre-oscars party a couple years ago and
I remember he was just shocked and I
actually saw our producer Alex mace at
the same party which is so funny
um but yeah I mean a lot of people don't
know that Leo actually is the reason
that I was cast in the original orphan
because I'd never worked on anything
before it was kind of one of the first
couple of you know big auditions that I
had and uh
they were looking for someone with
blonde hair and blue eyes which my
natural hair color is not actually
blonde surprise surprise
um and so they a lot of people didn't
actually watch my tape but Leo watched
my tape when he was um out on location
filming and he called the studio and he
said that it's Isabelle or I'm taking
the movie someplace else so I really
kind of owe him my entire career because
it was because of him that I got cast in
the movie and I actually didn't even
know that until halfway through filming
when Leon DiCaprio took me to lunch at
the Polo Lounge as a kid with my mom and
I remember just sitting there and
pinching myself because I couldn't
believe it
um so I I'm a huge fan of his and I I
really just appreciate his his support
and and and for really
being the reason that I'm doing this
because I I love this career so much I
can't imagine doing anything else yeah
very cool really him taking a chance
welcome home Esther we left it just as
it was
it's lovely to be back I miss my family
very much
Isabel what was it like for you to jump
back into this character I guess more
specifically what was it like for you to
see yourself de-aged in this I'm sure
there's a process of trial and error but
then when you saw it completed what was
that like for you and jumping back into
the role was so exciting and terrifying
at the same time but revisiting Esther
was something that I kind of had to do
and that no one else could do and I
would really pissed if anybody else did
it and uh and I think seeing the movie
for the first time you know I was just
shocked honestly I mean even though I
was there every single day for all the
like tricks that we did with the camera
with the lighting to practically age me
back in time because we didn't use any
visual effects it wasn't until I saw the
movie for the first time that I really
kind of
had my jaw hit the floor and go whoa we
actually did it because I found it to be
so much creepier than the first one
because somehow we made me look like a
kid again and I'm just excited for the
fans to see it honestly as you said
there was no no like special effects
well not special but there was no like I
guess digital effects but what was it
like doing all that stuff practically
for both of you oh it was so fascinating
um we had like a little chair they tried
to make to make to help me walk but it
had to be driven by somebody else and
then my shoulders weren't moving so I
remember the first time we were like
it's like you know just gliding it
Nestor just flies all of a sudden so it
was really trial and error and we kind
of discovered that these
massive platform boots that Julia
Warrior is basically in every scene that
we did in the movie together and me
squatting simultaneously kind of fit the
bill for the scenes that we were in when
you see both of us together and then I
had a body double two of uh two of them
Sadie and uh Kennedy who were wonderful
young actresses who played me and played
Esther from every angle and we really
got to like co-create her movements
together in this movie
um and then I think the only you know
facial effect that we did is I wore
contact lenses that made my my eyes
bigger but that was really about it
everything else was just kind of you
know on the day yeah Julie what was it
like for you seeing it seeing the
finished version of that because I'm
sure you know as is about to mentioned
platform boots and you know all these
sort of practical effects that have to
happen to make it I'm sure from your
perspective on your shooting seems like
a you know like one thing but then when
you see it finish you're like oh yeah
that's it this this works I mean it's a
Testament to Brent our director and our
producers that we nobody no none of the
actors on set were like this isn't going
to work um we all went uh all in and I
think um yeah if you if you zoomed out
into the movie while we were making it
well you know it looked ridiculous like
I it was pretty humiliating to have to
walk around with big Gene Simmons
platform boots on all the time
um and be like towering over other
people
um and and Isabelle got an amazing like
thigh workout because she was walking
around with bent legs the whole time
um
so it seems kind of silly from the
outside but we didn't get distracted by
it and we were able to I I when I saw
the movie finally cut together I was
like whoa
um they really pulled it off and
Isabelle also like it wasn't just about
making her tinier or shorter than
everybody else there's a whole demeanor
and way that she talks that is very
convincing as a child and the whole
movie hinges on that because she's got
to be able to trick this family and they
never did it with uh with uh like CGI or
digital
digital manipulation so yeah that's very
cool very like a very old school
filmmaking
um Julie what was the draw for you were
you a big fan of the original film I
don't I remember the original film being
really popular I'm too much of a wimp
for horror movies and I think in
particular when we uh when I was sent
the script to the prequel
um it was the world was so scary enough
that I I couldn't stomach watching scary
movies but also there's something about
working on a movie like this if you're
not the villain if you're not the main
character then usually you're just like
in distress the whole time and that's
not as exciting but why I read the
script and I uh got to the Twist and the
twist is even like more amazing than the
twist I think in the first one
um and I thought oh my God this is so
good and so clever the scripture was
just really really good and and also has
fun we have fun in the movie because now
the audience is in on the secrets that
um we're just watching this Esther and
Elena you know trick all these grown-ups
and going like how much longer is she
going to get away with this yeah it
seemed really fun to me if that's a
weird word for a horror movie yeah no
absolutely no of course of course it is
what should the audience know about the
twist heading into it without I guess
giving too much away well first of all
you can enjoy the movie regardless
because again we've said it a lot like
we're we're in on it with Esther so
watching this anti-hero
um trick people and manipulate and
wondering how far she's gonna push that
um or is she gonna get caught like that
that is part of the fun and then my
character you know I say in the trailer
the mother protects her family
no matter what so Esther in some ways
has kind of met her match because
there's this woman that that um is so
desperate to keep her family together
and to make this work
um but she kind of looks at Esther and
knows that something's off and
something's weird and so you're just
waiting for her to figure it out and
what is she gonna do when she does
figure it out Julia it's been 10 years
since Silver landing's Playbook I'm
tired I want to go no no no no no no no
no we haven't we haven't even finished
the salad yet or or the the duck I made
the fire and ice cake I said I'm tired
what do you remember about shooting Matt
I was so happy to be a part of that
movie it was a pretty crazy experience
um I remember being really impressed
with Jennifer Lawrence and uh yeah I uh
I learned a ton on working on that movie
um
yeah oh my God 10 years what are you
talking about